have they gotten any of the showbiz bug
would they want to be and go into acting
sami
i think would be more interested in
directing and photography
fast forward a few years and denise
richards is not far off her 18 year old
daughter with charlie sheen sammy just
confirmed that dream in an insta-story q
a telling her followers she wants to
write and direct her own screenplay
whatever they want to do i just want
them happy and follow their passion and
their heart the reveal came just a day
after sammy shocked the internet with
the news she's joining only fans here's
her big announcement posing in a bikini
she captured the post click the link in
my bio if you want to see more i think
we just want our child to pursue
whatever would make them happy you know
and if that's what they believe
would make them happy then then
absolutely as long as they have
something to fall back on some real job
so we have a feeling charlie's probably
okay with sami's hollywood aspirations
but that whole only fans thing yeah
dad's not on board while denise showed
some love in the comments of sammy's
news saying quote sammy i will always
support you and always have your back i
love you charlie slammed the career move
and blamed his ex for sammy even
launching her account in a statement to
et he says quote she is 18 years old now
and living with her mother this did not
occur under my roof
you might be asking why the big concern
since only fans is a platform for all
content creators but it's gained a
reputation as the go-to social media for
adult entertainers which is why charlie
might be having trouble with the idea
now some have called out charlie's
response as hypocritical given his
history with sex workers charlie came
over for thanksgiving for dinner uh a
few years ago and he had a hooker in the
car in the driveway and he's like uh you
know was afraid to tell me well she's in
the driveways okay she's in the driveway
i'm like
[Music]
i said i'll set a plate
still his statement continues quote i do
not condone this but since i'm unable to
prevent it i urge her to keep it classy
creative and not sacrifice her integrity
but denise doubled down supporting their
daughter telling e.t quote sammy is 18
and this decision wasn't based on whose
house she lives in all i can do as a
parent is guide her and trust her
judgment but she makes her own choices i
don't ever want to push my kids to do
something they don't want to do but i
encourage them if that is something they
want to do than to try it
and explore different things and it's
nice to see denise and sammy in a good
place the mom and daughter have had a
bit of a rocky relationship in recent
years in 2021 sammy shared a
sense-deleted tick-tock claiming she was
living in an abusive household with her
mom she moved in with her dad at the
time but she has since gone back to
living under denise's roof and now sammy
and denise seem to have repaired their
relationship they just spent mother's
day together you really
reevaluate and see what's important and
things that you love and sometimes it's
the simplest things and as she takes the
next steps into adulthood looks like
sammy's got her mom's full support to
love someone that much it's just it's
unbelievable
[Music]
you